brighter than the sky I changed
everyone's plans to walk you guys
through this one shot you guys saw the
shot you guys I'm talking about you saw
it I don't you know explain it let's go
I want this to come together out of thin
air like in fortnight
right when you build stuff in fortnight
pieces what I got here is a noodle wall
so I clone just a cylinder and make sure
it was all due to the measurements of
the actual foam wall once I have my
phone wall modelled group everything
into one drop-down so I can just work
with that one mama
first thing I'm stacking effects I threw
the noodle wall into a fracture object
and in the fracture object I told it to
not just look at the whole thing but
break it up into all the different
segments that it's made out of next
thing throw that into a random effector
randomly moves all the objects in your
you know whatever you put into the
randomizer randomizing to position it
randomizes the scale and rotation I'm
gonna put the random effector into
another effector that is called the push
apart I don't want to push them apart I
want them to go from nothing and scale
up to their final size to push apart
effect actually has a drop down here in
their mode called scale apart that's
what I'm animating I'm animating the
scale apart and I'm animating the random
effector and that is going to give us
the look of this phone wall
materializing out of thin air that's
what I love so much about cinema is you
have all these cool things in this
program that allow you to do a bunch of
fun stuff and you get to tweak them in a
bunch of fun different ways
that's what it looks built from the
outside in you know it finishes on the
inside that's that's the that's the gist
of animating the wall now we're in a
position where I need to put this
animation into shot that is very shaky
I'm not the best camera tracking Loretto
the way you camera tracking works is
that it actually tracks dozens of points
across the shot figures out how all
those points move in relation to each
other to figure out a 3d camera moving
through space my problem here is that
there's not enough detail so yet unsharp
mask and I've talked about this in the
previous video before you have to add
three different layers of unsharp mask
it it's it's a gross looking shot but
it's now ready to track so that's what
I'm gonna do my exported that as an
image sequence and then I opened up the
3d camera tracking program of choice for
me which is Buju because that's just the
one that we still have if I track the
features go to advanced and sometimes I
go to large-scale that seems to track
things a little better but for this when
I go through normal scale next search
this is 30 this is a fast-moving shot
since the TV you don't want to bump up
all that high let's start
what exactly makes this shot hard to
track there's a lot of noise and I don't
mean like like classic noise you'd get
in on an image sensor I mean like visual
noise in the sense that there's a lot of
different things that are hard to
differentiate from each other
for instance the computer struggles with
telling the difference between different
blades of grass and so it might be
tracking one point and then all of a
sudden that tracking point moves to a
different spot in the video and it you
end up with inconsistent and so it ends
up giving you a wonky track and to
resolve that you have to actually go in
and manually track the points you want
to track stuff that's really far away
stuff that's really close to the camera
stuff that moves throughout the sequence
especially the best things you can track
are things that have been completely
obscured by the camera for some point in
time but then come back before the end
of the shot because the computer doesn't
know the difference between a point here
and a point at the end of the shot
because it disappeared for a while but
because humans have contexts and are
able to apply that I know that that
point is the same so I can establish and
tell the computer that it's the same so
now that I've gone through I've added
all those manual tracking points I threw
it into the camera solved to figure out
the 3d camera and then it spits out this
3d camera so as you can see here here's
all these tracking points you can see
all the points in the distance better
track the mountain the big tree off in
the distance here is we're all right
here right here at the front and I
kicked this out to cinema 4d and that's
work Clint takes over and actually put
the stuff in the scene and we are back
so now what we're gonna do is take the
animation on that wall and put it into
the scene that red tracked it you guys
can see here bird's-eye view of kind of
the scene you can see virtual me running
with this camera all these yellow lines
what are these yellow lines
that's the fall-off for all of these
walls I don't know how to hide those yet
I tried searching on Google I don't know
how we have
four copies of the wall lined up next to
each other that's just where they need
to be for the shot to make sense for the
story and the seed has been changed for
all these walls so the same basic
animation is happening but in different
ways you know it's like if you make a
pizza every pepperoni pizzas not exactly
the same no in this case if I'm like
worried that oh I don't know if the
track was good or not then I would just
render out like a really low res version
of this animation and bring it in After
Effects incompetence see if it works but
I don't need to do that because Ren is
really good at tracking stuff so another
great go grill plug-in is light kit bro
it's really cool because it lets you use
essentially a sunlight tool to control
the Sun in sign of cinema 4d in
combination with the HDR I studio rig I
am lighting the scene with an HDR eye a
lot of great school gorillas stuff is
like things that you can do in cinema 4d
but it would take you like 10 times
longer so they've streamlined and get
you to that final results so much faster
on top of that I want the shadows from
these foam walls to be comped into the
final shot so what I'm gonna do is throw
a floor down and on that floor I'm using
a shadow catcher material does exactly
that it catches the shadows two things
kind of happening the background we have
Gabe who is rotoscoping Niko and Ren
running through the scene because the
fences are gonna be on the right they're
gonna be in front of all these fences
that gave us to go through shot by shot
by hand cut out
Ren and Miko once this render is done it
goes to Ren for the final pass storm
father and at that point storm father
renders out the very final shot remember
this episode is brought to you by
Squarespace and whether you need a
domain website or online store make your
next move with Squarespace just like
this security system here Oh who's
coming back from lunch
what's the passphrase what the
passphrase passphrase yeah we got a new
everyone has a passphrase now did you
say email or something
no no I don't know I know my code might
be a school but give me one fact about
Squarespace ok where's face.com
has award-winning customer service is
that 24/7 customer service yes
congratulations Clint your passphrase is
Squarespace has 24/7 award-winning
customer service you'll need it every
time you enter that next at the studio
squarespace.com has award-winning
customer service yep 24/7 24
the only way you can enter is if you
tell me a fact about Squarespace
Squarespace is flexible for any kind of
website whether you're a musician or a
designer or an artist or anything like
that you can use Squarespace to easily
design your websites
that's really good Ren don't forget that
you're gonna need it to come in the
studio from now on I changed everyone's
pants - yo Neko yo what's the passphrase
no that's your PIN
what's your passphrase everyone has a
passphrase now I didn't I didn't get
this email Sam Sam
what's the passphrase dude cheese and
crackers no I'll give you a hint
okay it's a a Squarespace fact is this
like a trick no how about a really cool
stylish for easy templates or something
probably
Squarespace keeps all your code base up
to date so you never have to worry about
updating your website for new browsers
clearance level 5 you may now enter the
studio it was they've got a war
are they beautiful yes do you work to do
this is my job hey Gabe hey what's
what's your passphrase dude
Squarespace offers unique domain
experience that's fully transparent and
simple to setup I always knew there was
something special about that guy what
how many bugs do I have yeah now that
Clint has built the assets and rendered
out the shot I'm gonna composite it so
remember these are two different stages
of the effects process you gotta make
the elements and then render it out to
create it into a real thing and now I
gotta add it to the footage and it's not
just a matter of putting it on top of
the footage as we learned in that
previous video what was that previous
video now the walls move with the camera
that's great but they're obviously on
top of Niko and I so that doesn't work
we're going to rotoscope Niko and I
think Gabe did that and they don't they
don't match the shot they're too bright
the two contrasts are too saturated and
the shadows are way too dark so I have
to somehow separate the shadows bring
those down this is how I did that and
right off the bat you can see the
shadows are actually built into the shot
I know of a great trick to get rid of it
so check this out if I add the extract
filter it's kind of like keying out dark
stuff or light stuff if I slide this
down it'll start keying out anything
that's bright and I don't want to key
out what's bright so I'm gonna count
what's dark and just like that the
shadow because it was like basically
straight black was able to be removed
numbers man so here are my walls first I
used extract
got rid of the shadows entirely that's
okay because I just duplicate that layer
later as you can see here add a bit of
fast blur and you want to tint it to the
same color of the shadows of the scene
and add the shadows in and now the
shadows look more normal and already you
can tell a big difference
they look like apart from the fact that
they're on top of Niko they look like
they're sitting just above the ground
here another thing I added was ambient
occlusion is proximity darkness it's not
actual shadow is more just the absence
of light so here's without ambient
occlusion here's wit without weight
without weight the next thing I added
was levels I also have info panel so if
I click up here I actually go down to
HSB this is pretty much the number one
tool I use for trying to mesh renders to
a scene
what is the brightest part of our shot
it's the sky here so just hovering my
mouse over the sky I can see the
brightness is set to 93 percent if I
hover over here and say a bright spot
right above this blue here that's
sitting at 100% brightness that means
the render is brighter than the sky that
shouldn't be the case and also the
shadows I'm gonna raise the shadows a
little bit and but then I'm also gonna
increase the gamma kind of add some
contrast back in now on top of that I
added what's called color match shirt
but it's from red giant King suite which
is pretty much the best King suite out
there for After Effects has all these
really cool effects that allow you to
match a green screen element to the
background but it also works great for
matching renders to the backgrounds and
then the other effect I used all the
time is which is also from red giant
edge blur edge blur is fantastic because
it just blurs out the edges of an object
without blurring the interior of it this
is basically matched to the shot now
obviously it's underneath Niko and I so
I literally bring out Nikolai and boom
look at that well look at that we're on
top of the world so this is an actual
digital cutout frame-by-frame
manual-labor of Niko and myself away
from the footage yeah this is pretty
decent like it blends in nice enough
that it looks like it belongs there
it may not be photo perfect but hey this
shot 271 frames long that's three
seconds so I get a lot of questions
about whether or not color grading
should come before or after visual
effects are done and the answer is
always after but once the shot is
rendered there's still one last thing
you got to do and that's to put that
rendered file back into the Edit which
is what Clint was super in charge of
this whole process as the director
Clint's finished this off
[Applause]
guys I really appreciate your interest
in these these tutorials and these
effects they take a long time took a
long time to figure out how to do it's
so much fun though and it's really fun
to share with you guys like how this
process works it means a lot I really do
appreciate your guys's interest in this
kind of stuff yeah I hope you guys like
the video it's not a work if you're not
subscribed each bug subscribe gonna give
Jake a little piece of his own security
medicine here and just walked out for a
phone call and I'll watch the door on
them nah you're not above the law you
gotta give me that Squarespace fact you
can get 10% of your first purchase by
going to Squarespace comm / corridor
crew checks out think I'd forget